You're going to tell me about the the
fatalities that happened in the in the work
there. There's one in the quarry
quarry. Yes well the other fatality
happened in the face of
a quarry. It seems that they had
the power to monkeys had blasted
a very large mass of granite
and it was balancing
on the quarry ledge and the
quarrymen were working down below
and all of
a sudden that mass of granite
became unbalanced and my shout
went round look out look out and they all
sprang away from the face except one man
who sprang back against the face
and when the stone fell it crushed
him against the face of the quarry. His
name was percy poole. I knew him personally
. Percy poole or my brother in law.
George leslie what now deceased
. He was
a big strong young man of about twenty
six cliff fifteen or sixteen stone quite
like the greek god apollo he picked
percy poole up like this who you know
a ten year old boy picked him up and carried
him down to the dressing station. But
the man was dead. Percy pool. And
another incident was when harry
waters who was a contemporary
of my father. Harry waters had
a job of being a dog man
for a crane a dog man as
a man that fastens
a hooks onto crane loads. And harry waters
used to form the habit of riding on
the courage of the crane rather than
run along after it and i missed this
particular day mr joe wright
a crane driver didn't see harry sitting on
the body of the crane and he swung this
mobile steam crane around and
it crushed. Harry water society
and he died very soon after that. Without
any other incidents like that around the
place anything in the standard thing sheds
no accidents there. Yes yes there's one
now you recall the need of outlining
this. There was one man there. George
walton full blooded scotsman
who used to play the accordion
at the caledonian dances. He
used to for most melodiously and
george walton work just opposite
me and i saw walton had
he had his stone. The granite block it
must have been an eight feet long. He had
the dogs in it and the electrical crane
driver had lifted it up off the ground and
walden wanted to work. What we call the
joints of the stone which meant to say to
put blocks hundreds of stop it from falling
over it was standing up vertically. And
he picked up
a block and instead of catching hold of
the block end for end for safety sake
he forgot. And he put one hand under the
block and the other over the block and
the dogs. Came out the dogs holding to
a block of granite flew out and
a stone fell and caught. Walton's
hand and it crushed his finger off
first finger off to the first joint
now that man he was about sixty five
but he held his hand like so and with
fortitude with fortitude that man of sixty
five. He walked about 400 yards down to
the dressing station to have his crushed
finger dressed. That convinced me
about the fortitude of the scotchman
jim of the men who used to work in the
in the workshops there at the quarry
there who used to sharpen the tools used
to call you call them the tools sharps
they were correctly named
tool shops a blacksmith is
a very capable person tools
sharp is more highly
specialized still because
a blacksmith cannot show cannot
sharpen and temper steel
like the professional tool shop
can. But these tools sharps were
the key men of the job. There were about
eight or ten of them and without them
we ran
a pylons would never have been constructed
just those eight or ten men were the key
. Men because they had the skill to temper
the steel to stand up to the granite
chisels and punches and machine chisels
and drills and so forth. They were the
specialized men. And there was one man
in fertik ular richard if you can recall
yourself mckenzie he was a
foreman mckenzie was a us
a man about eleven stone
dark except fellow very
doer to use
a scotch term he boasted of nothing but
there's one thing he did boast of that he
used to temper steel and
punches to stand up to
a granite in scotland called
the brunswick black and it's
a highly impregnated with carbon and very
very hard but this man had successfully
tempered steel to stand up to the
brunswick black and that was his boast
. You know there's no no comparable granite
like that in australia there is there
is we have in this country we have granites
of various colors and including black
and some of the some of the black granite
of this country is as hard as the hobbs
of hell to use
a common expression. The man who sharpened
the tools there and how long did it take
you to wear one down to the point where
it had to be resharpened oh that's an
interesting question. Well that's largely
dependent upon the skill of the tool shop
. So you sometimes tool
shop. Used to air in his
judgment and the tool would either turn out
to brittle and therefore it would crack
and fly or be too soft. But this
used to happen and if it did happen.
All you did was throw that tool away
from your stone into the corridor where
it was from one massive granite chip chip
so your tool over there rejected and we
all did the same and there was a
man employed retired who wasn't
a retired member he was an
ex mason who used to wheel
a barrow up and down the shed collecting
the blunt tools and taking them to
a blacksmith. And each blacksmith had
a way of determining which were his tools
one way or brought back to the blacksmith
shop he would select his chisels and punches
from the pile. I must have had them
branded or some way but he wouldn't it
wouldn't take the blame for the other
fellow's bad work. You know. Yes.
How long did it take you two to
complete one stone. I mean other than
a forty thousand dollars stands on the
hardwood bridge pylons and piers. Now how
long did it take you to complete say one.
Well i don't mind confessing that as an
apprentice. I wasn't expected
to work as laboriously as
a mason on full money but nevertheless
it used to take me five a week to
a fortnight to finish one stone. But down
there. They used to race each other they
were jealous of each other's capacity to
turn these units out you know they use
a race but they was one man there who i
to day think had the right attitude of
mind and his name was kennedy.
Jim kennedy. Jim kennedy was
a man and one of the first men to come
onto the job or jim kennedy another was
george walton had his finger
crossed off and comer on.
Crookshanks jimmy croup shanks and
other. Well this particular man
. Yes jim kennedy her had been a lot
right attitude. It was going to be
a five year contract and jim candy wasn't
going to kill himself he was going to
take it easy. I don't know
the man might have had
a bad heart. I used to think he must have
had because him kennedy used to stand by
his down and have
a gaze around. He worked adlib he
didn't didn't extend himself one bit.
And do contract was finished
on time. You know what sort of
speed. Did the how long did it
take the fastest masons to do
a block. Well i would say one week. One
week there would be the average time of
a mason completing a stone is.
Forty thousand weeks. That's
a lot of weeks is over. Yes yes and
there was one man there apart from
here. Of one day. Q did she go. Apart
from him. There was another fellow called
dizzy low and he was lightly named he was
a six foot man black as the ace
of spades. But tough and they
were the way that man used to belt into
that granite he used to make some of the
other fellows look like apprentices he
was so strong. How many. He absolutely
gloried in beating the other fellow for
these down to the skirts in the some of the
skirts and the italians used to compete
against each other. Did i don't i don't
think so. I don't think so. But what i
mean is me is that the tenacity of the
scottish character. These men were
brought out. And their families and the
average man was past middle
age and yet they used to work
furiously and their their constitutions
i must have had iron constitutions
to work the way they did you hear granite
constitutions. That's the correct word. I
couldn't think of
a granite men they were granite constitutions
yes. Do you remember the manager
there. Mr.
Gilmore. Yes i've already
referred to my interlude with
mr.
John gilmore and his triumph over me. Where
did he live. He lived down the river in
an old historic place
a very beautiful home up on the southern
bank of the river towards the mouth of the
river. It had been the property
of i saw miller name mr.
Arthur ready. But when the sawmill closed
down and norman on long set themselves up
there. This lovely drawing on the side
of the who hill was allocated to mr.
Gilmore and family and there they lived the
full term of the bridge in fact one of
the daughters. I just wrote can't recall
her first name is still occupying that
house. Yeah and and the
company the company supplied
a nice little speedy motor launch that
plied between the quarry and dwelling
for the convenience of the manager and his
family he used to go home for lunch back
and his son jock gilmore. Three
or four years older than i
was the driver of that
launch. So i surmise. But
was getting a retainer
a retainer retainer from the company
to operate that launch. Plus his
meager i emphasize the word his migo
apprenticeship money to supplement that
retainer. I wasn't altogether to wake
up to this when i was an apprentice
didn't cross my mind but i worked it
out since he were born down a maria of
a word you. Yes i am
a native of maria i was born on gun there
lee hill in the year nineteen zero
nine. That makes me seventy
three years of age. I don't
feel seventy three. I don't know whether i
look seventy three. Richard i don't feel
seventy three. But i was born there.
nineteen zero nine. And my father before me
was born in 1873 outside of maria at
a place called do wires creek your
schooldays down there are only
two well. Bob colfax and
i were contemporaries.
We were schoolmates. And bob
cole facts has eulogised the
headmaster whose name was
patrick egan. Bob cole facts
loves to refer to. Patrick egan
as the prince of pedagogues
because he was
a very very well-informed man and had
the art of teaching and these success
that he had with his pupils namely
bursary bursary attainments was amazing
and all the colfax family in fact when i
say all there are one two three boys and
two girls all attain bursaries under the
instruction of egan. And bob
colfax for the satisfaction of
posterity i refer them to bob cole faxes
story memory lane in which he elaborates
on his school days at maria as
a matter of fact bob colfax
recently supplied me with
a manuscript outlining it.
It all and i typed that
manuscript out and i'm about to send
a copy of it. Plus the manuscript back
to colfax in maria. But i have had
a friend of mine read that
manuscript and she she's
a native of the south coast and she's truly
amazed at how cold facts and aberrated
on the system of education that
was afforded we children of those
days period and it was a good education.
It was excellent. It was marvelous. As
a matter of fact when you reached fifth
and sixth class you were receiving
secondary school education secondary
school education such subjects as
trigonometry algebra quadratic equations
and all the higher branches of education
were imparted to us by patrick egan in
fifth and sixth class. How many teachers
were there at the school. There were about
three lady teachers and one man. Patrick
egan and that took you up to high school
to this. Yes the fifth and sixth class but
took it up to high school standard in
fact one of the call faxes gord
on that's bob's brother. He got
a super duper pass in the bursary
which entitled him to go straight
to high school when he came
to sydney and that gordon is
a teacher in wool and gong today. The
bursaries were to which high school.
I mean you could go to any high school
where was the area how school then. Well.
Sydney high school they were they were
sent to sydney high school these gordon
colfax is one and his sisters. Yes.
Do you have anything else about
. Maria in those days. Do you. While
some of the most inspiring days
of my life were spelt spent
on my native soil and i remember
i was a bit of
a loner and i used to roam around
the countryside by myself and
i remember one day. I thought
to myself i go and have
a look at brown leave the island which
has been written up by the state
historian and i walked down to the mouth
of the marina river which is about
five mile five mile and i walked three mile
along the beach to brownlee island and
all by myself and walked through the
bush by the time i got back home i musta
covered about twenty miles. And i was
so thirsty that i didn't have the
the good sense to go and ask a resident for
a drink of water. I had a drink out of
a horse trough. I drank the water out of
the horse trough that's how thirsty i was
. Can you think of any other stories
about maria. Richard a very dramatic
a very dramatic episode i shall relate.
My father. Was in the habit of
visiting his brother who was
a farmer and my father used to
take we for children with him.
And after having had
a lovely day on the farm. My father would
help his brother milk the cows and we
would sit around the table and
have our evening meal and we would
start to wind our way home after dark. We
had to cross the river. That is to say
that my father's brother used to go
down to the river with us and row us across
the river. And row the boat back to his
side and from that point we used to
depart and go across the hills to
a distant. Farming locality further
up the river named cairo or
we lived at kai or well my
father got up into the hills and
he was
a very good bushman and he knew the country
like i knew the back of his hand but
this was
a very dark night and my
father missed his way and at
a certain point and i father said
don't move and he was carrying
my youngest sister in his arms he said
don't move and we all stopped dead
and my father became more
fully aware of his situation
and richard the dramatic incident
i am about to state is my
father was standing on the edge of
a mine shaft. One step further. My
father would have been down the shaft
with his youngest child in his
arms. Now i often say to myself
there something in that
shakespearian quotation. There is
a dead divinity which
shapes our ends. There is
a destiny or divinity which shapes our
ends rough few them out. We will my father
was between life and death at
that moment but something had
a presentiment. And he said stop.